hey what's up guys my name is Hoshino
and welcome to another Sparky dev vlog
so when I keep this one short it's been
quite an eventful week I've done quite a
few things that I wanted to get done
which is good the first thing I did was
in fact I don't even remember where we
were at last week but basically I added
the cube mapping configuration for
Direct X so now DirectX can load texture
cubes here as you can see it's a little
bit different with direct accent is with
OpenGL mainly because of the way that it
wants the data packed and in the end you
just create texture two days because the
thing is apart from creating just cube
maps remember we're not taking in just
like six images or just a single kind of
cross right so for example what I mean
by that is if we look at sandbox we've
got under PVR and cube map you know
we're not taking in like a single one of
these right it's we're actually taking
in like you know eleven of them in this
case because they are the different Maps
right and you actually have to supply
the maps because otherwise like if if we
get it to generate them for us it's not
gonna look anywhere near as good and
we're gonna be able to notice the seams
in the edges of the cube map so we - we
supply the maps which is the standard
way of doing things anyway like if you
look at direct or all surfaces so those
are the dot DDS files those contain like
all the maps for a texture packed into
them immediately and you can kind of
generate them using the DirectX texture
tool now I'm not using any of that stuff
and that's actually quite an old thing
anyway I'm not using any of that stuff
of course because we're not primarily
focus on DirectX and that's not really
the only API we're using anyway not that
you couldn't get a director or surface
file to work with OpenGL that's
absolutely it's very very
straightforward to do that it's just
that I don't really want to subject
myself to DirectX tools or anything like
that so eventually I probably picture
because having you know so many MIPS I'm
you can see there's actually the same
map and like different formats here but
having eleven MIPS for a 1024 by 1024
cube map and then you know having to
maintain even separate MIPS for just
attached to two days is gonna be a bit
of a chore so I think that more or less
eventually when Sparky probably has its
own image format and its own texture
format that is probably when we'll talk
about maybe having a tool that will
autumn automatically generate all the
maps for us all that we can supply you
know every map level and it will
actually output a single file for us
which Sparky will then read that that's
a possibility in the future obviously
for something like if we look at GL
texture 2d we've got it
generating map maps automatically for 2d
textures and for the most part for 2d
textures I would say it's totally
reasonable to get automatic map
generation I'm trying to get it to work
in DirectX which is proving difficult
because DirectX really isn't meant for
map map generation like you're supposed
to kind of provide that stuff kind of
offline or to calculate that stuff
offline and then generate it so I am
generating them here and there are a few
things here based on whether or not were
generating net maps but it doesn't seem
to actually work as of right now and I
didn't really spend too much time on it
but anyway yeah MIT maps and just
textures and all those kind of things
are something that ideally again would
be stored in a in an in like a custom
format specifically for the engine
that's usually the the way to go
obviously we would still support you
know unlike model formats where I'm
really reluctant to support anything
except for the sparking model format
especially because it's so easy to
convert anything into Sparky right you
just you just click and drag a model
file onto the build tool onto um the SVM
build tool and it will just
automatically output you an SVM file but
for textures I can see obviously how it
might be a bit annoying that anytime you
create a texture you have to
convert it into the right format and
like you have to do you have to generate
mint maps for and there might be like
this whole thing so I don't really want
to it will be an option there and oh
that's something that you should use for
probably especially for 3d right when
you're making all your textures however
I'm probably just going to accept like
PNG TGA stuff anyway all right cool so
that's the idea right now the biggest
thing that I've done though is the PBR
implementation so the physically based
rendering implementation is now working
on DirectX like for DirectX right so
DirectX PPR is basically complete there
are still a few things missing from
Sparky physically based rendering in
general namely stuff like ambient
occlusion maps and emit emissive maps
right there are a few things here and
there that are kind of missing that I do
want to add but it's just not the
highest priority right now so if we do
go to sandbox we can see that we are
running in direct3d mode if I hit f5
you'll be able to see the sandbox the
other thing I added was a cube map Oh
like a skybox or others so you can
actually see the skybox that you're in
right and if we yeah I mean this is as
you can see running in direct3d 11 so
there we go the only thing is the
normals look as you can see the normals
look very grainy and that's just because
again that normal map is not being
mapped properly that's the reason that's
not working but you can see general like
the cube map maps are obviously working
is they have those um spheres here look
very nice and the plastics here as well
the red ones everything seems to be in
order the other thing that I added
really quickly is a first-person camera
so that there has been an FPS camera for
a while and there's something and I just
chucked in but I actually did it
properly now so it's kind of similar to
the Maya camera in that in terms of like
it is correctly done it's not like a
hack so if I hit see here you can you
can use C by the way to toggle between
like a first-person camera and the Maya
camera yeah you test 3d and you can see
that you can move around shift kind of
makes you move a lot faster
ctrl + space go up and down does it look
anywhere you want and generally it works
really well and I actually quite liked
it for looking at stuff I think it's
quite nice not to mention the fact that
there are two cameras now so you can
actually just position this wherever you
want and then you know position this for
example on the other side of the cube
and you can see that I can kind of swish
between them which is kind of cool
anyway that's the way that that cookie
crumbles and then of course it escape
will release the mouse so that you can
use the debug menu and close the game or
do whatever you want so that's still of
course works quite nicely and then right
click again will capture the mouse that
you can move around all right cool
so that's the first person camera that I
added and then finally yeah there is the
skybox now the skybox is done very
easily there's not really much to it
drawing a skybox in general is very easy
to do there are two main ways to do it
there's the first way which is by
drawing a cube and then just sampling
the cube map at the cube from the cube
vertices which is the bad way of doing
it it's not really horrible or anything
it's just a bit unnecessary because well
because yeah but there's also the sphere
method as well how you can just draw or
latch like you can render a large sphere
with the back faces well with the with
the other faces like pointing inwards so
an inside-out sphere and then just
sample as well although there's the
normal way I think or the good way to do
it which is just simply to draw a quad
and then sample so you can see that I I
created a skybox here I'm just creating
a quad with the projection matrix of
that and the size of that so is from
negative 1 to positive 1 1 and then all
I'm doing is there's a shader for it
called a skybox trader and then all that
does is it's well it does use the
inverse of your projection matrix and
then just samples using the position
right so it's really simple to do and
then this is the lot that it's sampling
the disassembling so it's I'm not gonna
get into how this works now but
basically all we're doing here is we're
multiplying the vertex positions which
is the negative one positive one stuff
against the in the inverse the inverse
of the view projection right so that way
you get the inverse of the view
projection of the camera right which is
what we're generating here and then yeah
all we're doing is we're using those
outputs to sample B cube map and then
what we get here is really even though
it's just a quad we're just sampling the
texture at the right spots so in terms
of geometry all were rendering as a quad
but you can see that obviously we get a
skybox so that's the way that that works
it's probably the the proper way to
actually render a skybox but anyway that
that's it I don't think there's anything
else to add so if you guys enjoyed this
video please hit like button if you want
to support Sparky and get this and get
this code early then there'll be you can
hop over to patreon block home for slash
the churner there'll be a link in the
description and you can get it that way
and then finally the thing the other
thing that I wanted to mention well
firstly his patron so if you pledge $5
or more per month you get access to this
version repository which has all this
code that is on on github yet and then
finally I am preparing a github release
so if you go to bitly for Sparky Trello
to look at the Sparky Trello board you
can see there's a Marsh github release
checklist will probably make March I
imagine we've still got yeah I mean
we've still I like a week and a half so
we should make March but if you click on
the check list you can see kind of what
what I'm working on right so DirectX
PBL's done skybox is done all the stuff
that I need to do still over the next
week is gonna be opengl PBR so getting
that to work because I believe that
that's broken right now I'm mainly I was
mainly focusing on DirectX also like
this skybox for OpenGL doesn't even
exist yet as in like the shader for it
doesn't you can see there's only an HLSL
shader there's I need to convert my
mouse into row major because that's a
bit more optimal and then it just means
that rather than transposing our
matrices to put into DirectX will be
transposing our matrices when we put
them into
jail just because CPU side generally
row-major like matrix multiplication is
a lot faster than column-major
converting forward render to use system
uniforms because it's currently just
using material user uniforms
there's a forward there's a memory
controller and row which I like the
memory lake is this right
it's the command Q where we actually
when we submit a mesh we allocate these
bytes and we will we never delete them
because there's no real proper way to do
that yet
but I need to sort out this whole
command Q situation so really that's
going to be quite a difficult task
well not as difficult task but I'm gonna
have to make a proper like command
buffer filled with these render commands
that are actually that are actually
properly processed and then finally yeah
there's the 2d bitmap generation that I
want to get done in DirectX alright
thanks for watching I hope enjoy this
video and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye